bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette vidéo sur un sujet un petit
peu touchy un petit peu délicat à
aborder alors je vais pas prétendre
faire une
couverture complète de du sujetin ce
sera ça prendrait beaucoup trop de temps
et ce serait beaucoup trop ça touchera
beaucoup trop de sujets difficiles
surtout étant donné l'actualité mais en
gros on va parler de décolonisation de
la science et notamment de
décolonisation de la paléontologie le
but de cette vidéo ça va pas être de
vous donner une vision exo
de la question c'est une question qui
est vaste qui a beaucoup de ramification
notamment politique et vous savez que
sur ma chaîne je n'aime pas parler de
politique je veux parler de la science
mais ici il faut quand même aborder le
sujet parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'actualité là-dessus récemment on va en
parler de quelques-unes mais il y a il y
a beaucoup d'actualité et surtout c'est
un sujet qui est généralement
d'actualité et je voulais pas du coup
sachant qu'il y a des actualités qui
sortent par-ci par là en fait je voulais
pas aborder le sujet de façon vous savez
de disperser dans en plusieurs palaleo
news euh d'autant que c'est un sujet qui
est pas spécialement nouveau donc c'est
pas spécialement
euh pertinent de le faire dans des Paléo
news quoi euh mais surtout ce que je
voulais aborder c'était le le sujet en
fait euh de de cet article ici qui est
de renommer homo rodesiensis donc
homoodesiensis euh c'est le crâne de
Cabou le voici ce crâne de cabwe hein
c'est c'est un crâne c'est un crâne très
connu c'est un spécimen iconique hoti de
homorodesiensis homorodesiensis qui
depuis est considéré alors tout dépend à
qui vous parlez mais il peut être
considéré comme synonyme de homoedelberg
Enis mais bon c'est c'est problématique
parce que normalement homoedelberg Enis
c'est l'ancêtre de l'Homme de Néandertal
or même s'il a des ressemblances assez
vagues avec l'homme de Néandertal il est
fort peu probable que cet être humain
qui a vécu en zomie il y a 300000 ans
soit par fasse partie des cêtre de
l'Homme de Néandertal puisque la lignée
prénéandertalienne est déjà solidement
établie en Europe à l'époque et ils ont
déjà des caractères dérivés que
homoodesiensis n'a pas enfin que le
crâne de kabweé n'a pas donc c'est un
crâne qui que que dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler en tant que pré
pré néandertalien donc homoedlebergens
6is ou peut-être en tant que préhumain
moi généralement sur ma chaîne soit je
l'appelle homorodesiensis soit je
l'appelle Homo sapiens archaïque puisque
à 300000 ans il a de fortes chances de
plutôt appartenir à la lignée ancestrale
d' d'homosappiens ceci dit il diffère de
jebellirud qui est un vrai Homo sapiens
archaïque pour le coup enfin tu quis qui
est classiquement considéré comme un
homo sapiens archaïque par son front en
fait il a un front qui est extrêmement
fuyant alors que jebellirud le crâne de
jbellirud il lui ressemble beaucoup mais
le front est beaucoup plus droit et
surtout c'est un crâne qui est
absolument unique par sa robustesse
c'est un crâne vous voyez les bourlet
susorbitaires sont absolument d'une
épaisseur colossale l'os de du crâne de
caboué et d'une épaisseur colossale donc
il a il y a plusieurs raisons pour
considérer comomorodensis est une espèce
à part il y a plusieurs raisons pour
considérer qu'elle puisse être synonyme
d'autres espèces et le débat est en
cours il y a eu même récemment la
proposition homob bodoensis mais homo
bodoensis il y a aucune chance que ça
prenne puisque ça va être synonymisé
avec d'autres propositions qui avaient
été faites avant notamment rodesien 6
edelberg 6 ou sapience lui-même donc
c'est donc bref c'est c'est le le débat
scientifique était déjà suffisamment
compliqué comme ça hein d'après ce que
je viens de vous dire normalement ça
doit déjà vous avoir convaincu que
c'était un peu le bordel hein on n pas
on n'est pas on n pas on est d'accord
là-dessus mais en plus est venu se
rajouter à ça depuis quelques années
donc là je vous parle d'un article de
2021 mais c'est peut-être même avant ça
mais moi j'étais pas au courant du tout
c'est c'est un paléonanthropologiste qui
m'a dit ça c'est il s'est rajouté à ça
un débat depuis quelques années qui est
bah rodesien 6 ça fait référence à
Cécile rods et Cécile rods vous le
connaissez probablement pas parce que
c'était un un Mania britannique Cécile
rod il est responsable quasiment à lui
tout seul de toute la colonisation ou de
la de la colonisation d'une très très
grande partie du sud de l'Afrique
notamment bah de l'Afrique du Sud euh
pas de en tout cas pas des colonies du
cap mais au moins des des autres des
autres parties du pays qui forment
l'Afrique du Sud donc le orange free
state le roteng le kwazuluatal euh et
puis d'autres pays comme euh Zimbabwe et
Zambie qui sont devenus justement la
rodésie etz le mec il était tellement
mégalo il avait tellement le melon qu'il
y a un pays qui porte son nom la rodésie
ça vient de cecile rods donc le le
zimbabué la Zambie et notamment la
Zambie où on a trouvé homorod desensis
au début du du siècle der dernier sont
sont le l'œuvre on va dire de cet homme
quasiment seul en réalité la seule
volonté de cet homme évidemment il a pas
conquis les tous ces pays tout seul mais
c'est la volonté presque de cet homme
seul qui est responsable de la
colonisation du sud de l'Afrique d'une
bonne partie du sud de l'Afrique et de
l'Afrique en général et des malheurs
associés il y a ce monsieur qui a donné
son nom à la rodésie et la rodésie a
donné son nom à homoodésiensis et il y a
des gens qui aimeraient que ça change
qu'on change le nom résen 6 euh et moi
je je voulais touch je voulais vous lire
cet article là qui du pour du coup vous
offrir si vous voulez des pistes de
réflexion j'ai pas la prétention une
fois de plus de couvrir tout le sujet de
la décolonisation de la paléontologie
mais je trouvais que cet article- là
était intéressant et je voulais le lire
avec vous pour vous offrir au moins des
pistes de réflexion ceci étant dit le
problème de la le majeur problème de la
colonisation en paléontologie bah c'est
que la plupart des gens ne comprennent
pas quel est le problème c'est-à-dire
que voilà le rodesien 6 la rodésie c'est
loin c'est vieux je m'en fous voilà la
plupart des gens réagissent comme ça
d'autres gens vont vont réagir en disant
bah la rodésie enfin c'est c'est c'est
de l'histoire maintenant c'est on va pas
effacer l'histoire on va pas réécrire
l'histoire et je suis d'accord réécrire
l'histoire ne changera rien à ce qui
s'est passé par le dans le passé donc
tout ça on est ok on est
d'accord mais quel est du coup quel est
réellement le problème quel est le
est-ce que la science aujourd'hui est
encore col est-ce que et est-ce que
changer le nom d'une espèce comme ça ça
va soudainement résoudre le problème de
la colonisation de la science voyez
c'est ce genre de piste de réflexion là
que j'aimerais aborder avec vous et du
coup il se trouve qu'il y a aussi une
vidéo récente qui est sortie et qui un
peu involontairement mais c'est
précisément ça le problème
involontairement met exactement le doigt
là où la colonisation de la
paléontologie est un immense problème et
cette vidéo
c'est et qui me permettra du coup de
vous présenter une introduction à cet
article cette vidéo mais exactement le
doigt sur le problème et ce et cette
vidéo c'est j'achète un vrai dinosaure
sur internet de Morgan vs qui est une
vidéo alors c'est 1 million presque 1
million et demi d'abonnés 300000 vues et
plus de 20000 likes enfin presque 20000
likes pardon pas plus de 20000 likes
mais presque 20000 likes donc c'est une
vidéo qui a du succès c'est une vidéo
que les gens apprécient c'est une vidéo
que c'est je je vous dis ça je vous dis
ça parce que j'ai pas envie que vous
alliez sur la chaîne de Morgan vs pour
le pourrir en le pointant du doigt en
lui disant que c'est un [__] et
qu'il aurait jamais dû faire ça j'ai pas
envie que vous fassiez ça ce que j'ai
envie de pointer c'est l'attitude
générale il y a y a il y a une il y a
une forme d'attitude une forme de
comportement envers la paléontologie et
notamment la paléontologie des pays
africains qui est problématique dont
dont les gens gens n'ont pas réellement
conscience que les gens même apprécient
voilà de que les gens vont partager que
les gens personne va s'en rendre compte
en fait du problème fondamental qu'il y
a avec ce qu'a fait Morgan vs voilà et
ce que montre Morgan vs surtout dans
cette vidéo et c'est pas et du coup
c'est pas ce qu'a fait Morgan vs le
problème c'est l'attitude générale
autour de ça ça veut dire qu'on est tous
on fait tous partie de ce problème là de
quelle attitude est-ce que je veux
parler et bien cette attitude dont je
veux parler c'est Morgan vs donc qui
veut nous distraire en nous disant qu'il
a acheté un un dinosaure et que waouh
c'est trop bien je voulais vous le
montrer je voulais vous le partager
c'est extraordinaire et c'est tout à son
honneur de vouloir le partager autour de
lui hein il dit qu'il va vouloir le
montrer dans les écoles et cetera ok
admettons le problème c'est que ce
dinosaure bon déjà c'est pas un
dinosaure c'est un mosasaure mais c'est
surtout le le problème l'attitude
colonisatrice dont il dont il ne s'est
probablement pas rendu compte c'est
qu'on on a donc un citoyen français donc
d'un pays qui a colonisé le Maroc qui a
acheté un fossile sorti illégalement du
Maroc parce que je rappelle autant
l'exploitation et la vente des fossiles
est toléré au Maroc autant elle reste
illicite j'ai posé la question à un de
mes collègues paléontologues marocains
et il m'a répondu très sèchement c'est
illégal sur quoi j'ai dit tu es sûr
parce qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'export c'est illégal donc ça l'a
énervé quand je lui POS la question
voilà on en est à ce
niveau-là donc on a un monsieur qui dont
la nationalité est celle d'un pays
ancien colonisateur du Maroc qui a
acheté un fossile du Maroc qui a donc
été exporté plus ou moins pas super
légalement du Maroc et il fait tout ça
en faisant des blagues en portant un
costume de Tintin au Congo et il y a
300000 personnes qui qui qui ont vu
cette vidéo 19000 qui l'ont quiffit et
c'est pas normal voilà c'est c'est c'est
ça la colonisation les gens de manière
générale ne se rendent pas compte à quel
c'est tellement profondément engrainé
dans notre façon de penser que tout ça
est normal acheter des fossiles du Maroc
c'est normal se se déguiser en
aventurier c'est normal mais ce costume
d'aventurier bah c'est un costume de
colonisateur hein voyez les les petites
poches en pot de léopard le short tout
ça les chaussettes remontées il lui
manque plus que le casque hein le le
petit casque colonial blanc là et on a
le parfait costume et et si à ce
niveau-là vous êtes en train de vous
dire oui mais c'est moi qui suis un
connard je sais pas m'amuser je sais pas
machin je suis un rabageois je suis
dites-vous que essayez de vous
représenter ce que ça ferait si c'était
un fossile de votre pays il a été vendu
aux enchères et il a été acheté par un
mec d'un pays qui appartient à un pays
qui dans le passé a envahi votre pays ce
monsieur qui a acheté un fossile un très
très beau fossile de votre pays présente
une vidéo dans laquelle il va se vanter
d'avoir vanté d'avoir acheté ce fossile
dans un costume d'époque est-ce que vous
l'avez l'image en tête ça ça vous aurait
choqué mais ça ça n'a pas choqué les
gens ça ça ça ça ne vous choque pas
particulièrement et vous seriez
peut-être même prêt à le défendre et
c'est ça le c'est ça la colonisation
c'est justement ça c'est ce paradoxe là
le par de la de la colonisation de la
paléantologie c'est qu'il y a des choses
qu'on considère comme normal qu'on ne
considérerait pas comme normal par
ailleurs si ça ne concernait pas un pays
d'Afrique ou d'Asie du Sud-Est ou
d'Amérique du Sud et c'est ça le
problème de de pointer du doigt la
décolonisation de la science c'est que
soit on pointe dans la mauvaise
direction et les gens comprennent pas
soit on pointe dans la bonne direction
et soudainement les gens se sentent
offensés parce que ça les touche eux et
non faut pas se sentir offensé vous
n'êtes pas responsable du passé vous
êtes juste responsable du présent donc
ce qu'il faut c'est se rendre compte que
cette attitude existe on a l'impression
que c'est normal mais ça ne l'est pas ça
ne devrait pas l'être en tout cas autre
exemple beaucoup plus scientifique le
journal du monde nous parle de ubira
ubirajara jubatus qui est un qui est un
dinosaure du Crétacé du Brésil qui avait
été exporté illégalement en Allemagne et
donc quand les quand les enfin quand les
Brésiliens ont demandé bah vous pouvez
nous rendre notre ubira enfin vous
pouvez nous rendre notre dinosaure
ubirajara bah les Allemands ont dit non
ont juste dit non et puis du coup bah
ils se sont mis et bah du coup les
Brésiliens se sont mis à sonner la
clochette de la de la colonisation
justement ou en disant bah vous exportez
illégalement nos fossiles et maintenant
quand on vous demande de les rendre vous
nous les rendez pas non mais vous vous
croyez où quoi ils ont enfin ils ont
fait sonner le glas de la colonisation
et immédiatement tous les yeux se sont
tournés on est vers l'Allemagne en mode
les gars arrêtez de faire les cons là
quand même parce que là si si si on
commence à regarder dans les collections
des pays d'Europe on n'est pas sorti là
si vous commencez à faire chier là c'est
juste pour vous convaincre en fait ces
deux exemples là que je vous montre
c'est pas pour que vous alliez pourrir
les gens du Muséum d'histoire naturelle
de carsrour c'est pas pour que vous
alliez pourrir Morgan vs c'est bel et
bien pour vous faire comprendre que il y
a une attitude générale et que cette
attitude générale bah c'est ça la
colonisation c'est y a il y a une
attitude général à vouloir juste oublier
le passé et on veut pas il faut pas
oublier le passé c'est il faut vivre
avec moi personnellement et mon équipe à
l'université du VI watand et en Afrique
du Sud de manière générale on est engagé
justement dans cette voie de la
décolonisation donc par exemple on a
publié cet article qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire que de décoloniser la paléontologie
et ce qu'on propose c'est dans the
conversation d'ailleurs je vous encore
une fois je vous recommande d'aller voir
the conversation qui est un site écrit
par les scientifiques pour le grand
public donc c'est pas les journalistes
qui écrivent les articles ce sont
vraiment les scientifiques c'est la
vraiment la façon la plus directe de
communiquer avec les scientifiques donc
dans cet article on propose des façons
constructives en fait l'idée c'est de
reconstruire une histoire post-coloniale
et donc ça passe notamment par
reconnaître bah qu'il y a eu avant la
colonisation une paléantologie locale il
y avait déjà des gens qui s
au fossiles avant la colonisation donc
ce qu'on a appelé les les les les
chasseurs de fossiles du passé ou ce
qu'on a appelé aussi le la la
paléontologie indigène savoir que le mot
indigénus en anglais n'est pas aussi
connoté qu'en français donc en anglais
on parle de indigenous paléontology donc
la paléontologie indigène et on met à
leur crédit bah certaines découvertes
notamment le Mésosaure le Mésosaure qui
se trouve en ce moment à Paris a été
découvert par des populations locales en
Afrique du Sud n'a pas été découvert par
des scientifiques euh les par exemple
j'avais parlé plein de fois des
empreintes de pas de de dinosaures qui
ont été interprété par les bushem les
bushman avaient déjà correctement
interprété les empreintes de pas de
dinosaures comme appartenant à des
animaux qui étaient bipèdes et qui
ressemblait à des oiseaux bien avant la
culture que la culture préscientifique
que la culture scientifique ne les
atteignent donc tout ça cette
reconnaissance de la paléontologie
indigène c'est ça fait partie pour nous
d'une de ce qu'on appellerait une
décolonisation mais constructive donc ce
que nous on préfère appeler de
l'africanisation en réalité donc ça
s'applique en l'Afrique évidemment mais
reconnaître qu'il y avait une
paléontologie avant l'arrivée des
scientifiques c'est déjà une façon de
donner du Mérite aux gens qui étai là
avant et de dire bah vous voyez le la
paléontologie c'est c'est pas le c'est
pas le colonisateur qu'il l'a amené avec
lui euh la paléontologie c'est quelque
chose qui est qui existait déjà avant
l'intérêt pour les fossiles ça existait
déjà avant et le l'interprétation des
fossiles ça existait déjà avant
l'arrivée des colonisateurs faut pas
oublier le passé mais faut construire
par-dessus il faut construire quelque
chose de mieux et je sais pas si c'est
la meilleure des solutions c'est
probablement la solution qui fait le
moins de bruit euh parce que évidemment
ça ne choque personne il y a du coup la
solution destructrice qui consiste à
faire beaucoup de bruit euh et qui
consiste du coup à bah à prendre ce qui
a été acquis euh les acquis
scientifiques qui ont été faits durant
la colonisation et à leure défoncer la
tronche et le problème avec ça bah c'est
qu'on finit avec des situations comme en
Inde par exemple alors encore une fois
je vais pas vous faire la liste de tout
le toutes ces situationsl mais l'Inde
qui était donc un pays qui a été
colonisé par les Anglais euh a décidé
tout tout récemment en fait de supprimer
toute référence à la théorie de l'
éolution avant le niveau qui
correspondrait pour nous à la première S
en gros donc si tu es pas en première S
spsvt tu n'entendras plus jamais parler
de la théorie de l'évolution en Inde et
ça ça fait partie d'un programme de
décolonisation en tout cas c'est ce que
dit cet article ici tout le monde est
pas d'accord sur le fait ça pas été
ouvertement dit comme étant un problème
de colonisation mais ça fait partie en
fait de d'un d'un programme génér on va
dire de de décolonisation de la de
l'Inde de manière générale et de la
science en particulier ce que pointe du
Doig cet article et c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi cet article plutôt que
n'importe quel autre mais il y a
beaucoup d'articles qui ont évidemment
réagi il y a notamment nature qui a
réagi sur sur ça sur l'annulation pure
et simple de la théorie de l'évolution
dans les programmes scolaires indiens si
vous n'êtes pas en en
spsvt bah le problème c'est qu'on ouvre
la porte c'est ce qui est dit dans cette
conclusion c'est qu'on ouvre la porte en
fait à toute forme de créationnisme et
notamment dû au fait que Ben vous
recevez une éducation religieuse
généralement bien avant de recevoir une
éducation scientifique donc si vous avez
vous déjà être exposé au contrepoint de
cette éducation religieuse peut-être un
problème alors en plus si vous êtes
jamais exposé à ce contrepoint du
tout bon bah là c'est la porte ouverte
au créationnisme he quoi c'est c'est il
y a il y a un boulevard là maintenant
qui est ouvert en Inde en faveur du
créationnisme ce qui nous amène à un
exemple parmi tant d'autres de cette
décolonisation destructrice qui est bah
vouloir déconstruire euh
homorodesiensis parce que
homorodesiensis euh c'est l'espèce qui a
été nommé d'après la Rhodésie et la
rodésie a été nommée d'après Cécile
Rodes qui est un personnage que beaucoup
de personnes considère comme
problématique dans l'histoire de
l'Angleterre puisque comme je l'ai dit
quasiment à lui tout seul il a guidé
la politique de colonisation anglaise en
Afrique australe alors
romorodensis lisons cet article
justement et tirons-en quelques idées un
ancêtre des humains qui a été nommé
d'après Cécile rod devrait être renommé
dans un effort de décolonisation a-t-il
été discuté homorodésien nommé d'après
la rodésie qui qui est le nom anglais
impérial de ce qui est devenu depuis le
Zimbabwe et la Zambie devrait être
renommé homo bodoensis alors du coup
c'est effectivement l'idée l'idée ici
étant d'expliquer que c'est à l'occasion
de de homo bodoensis j'avais fait un
Paléo news he dessus mais c'est à
l'occasion de la nom de la création du
taxon homo bodoensis que le le débat de
sur homo rodesiensis a été prononcé le
homo bodoensis a un énorme problème
c'est que c'est juste un un synonyme
plus récent de taxon qui existe déjà euh
faut savoir qu'en taxonomie la règle la
plus inviolable de la taxonomie il y a
deux règles complètement inviolables en
taxonomie c'est la règle de priorité à
savoir que le premier nom qui a été
prononcé est le nom valide et homo
bodensis n'est qu'un synonyme plus
récent de fait de homoodesiensis
homoedelberensis bref ça désigne la même
chose donc homobodensis déjà
taxonomiquement c'est c'est foutu pour
lui en réalité c'est d'après les lois de
la taxonomie c'est foutu pour lui et la
deuxième loi la plus inviolable de la
taxonomie c'est vous n'avez pas le droit
de donner votre nom à une espèce et le
but de ces deux lois complètement
inviolables c'est d'éviter la
prolifération taxonomique c'est-à-dire
bah des gens qui nment des espèces à
tout va n'importe quand juste parce
qu'ils veulent r rentrer dans la
postérité voilà donc c'est déjà le le
premier niveau de problème qui est
engagé par cette idée de vouloir
remplacer homoodesiensis par homo
bodoensis ça ne marchera pas bon par
contre on peut débattre sur l'idée de le
renommer Elberg 6 il y a des il y a des
si vous voulez il y a des moyens moyen
détourner d'y arriver à contourner ces
deux règles inviolables mais c'est
extrêmement compliqué et personne ne
sera dupe qu'il s'agit d'une douille
c'est surtout
ça la reclassification est en partie
voulue pour éliminer cette association à
l'histoire coloniale de l'Empire
britannique mais aussi pour clarifier
une partie de l'évolution humaine les
scientifiques ont conduit des analyses
nouvelles des fossiles qui ont été
déterrés en Afrique et en Asie et qui
datent d' une période qui s'appelle
enfin que ils
appellent étant donné le son côté un peu
confus la période du du bordel du milieu
voilà le la la confusion du milieu ces
fossiles datent une période plus ou
moins similaire et à l'époque ont été
considérés comme étant distincts les uns
des autres donc homoedelbergensis et
homo rodagens 6 comme je le disais mais
les scientifiques considèent qu'ils
apparennent à une seule et même espèce
d'après cette nouvelle recherche donc
d'après la recherche qui a mener à euh
la création du nom homo
homobodoensis et et c'est là déjà qu'il
y a un problème c'est qu'en fait si vous
avez déjà deux noms pour désigner la
même chose bah en science on en
taxonomie on ne crée jamais un troisè
nom on va devoir choisir entre l'un et
l'autre mais la règle de priorité
taxonomique c'est que justement ça n'a
pas plus de sens de créer un troisème
nom et c'est bien ça qu'il faut se se
rentrer dans la tête en fait je sais que
pour nous enfin pour nous pour pour pour
les gens qui sont à l'extérieur du champ
taxonomique ça ça vous en touche une
sans faire bouger l'autre mais ce n'est
pas une solution logique en taxonomie de
créer un troisième nom parce que les
deux premiers noms c'était le bordel non
il va falloir décider lequel des deux
premiers noms était le vrai et on ne va
pas en créer un troisième on évite la
prolifération taxonomique à tout prix
donc ça c'est la logique taxonomique et
la logique taxonomique c'est pas de
créer un troème L Maron soi-disant
neutre au milieu pour pour faire plaisir
à tout le monde c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche il va falloir décider lequel
des deux rodesensis ou edelbergen 6 a la
priorité sur l'autre et normalement
c'est edelbergen 6 qui devrait avoir la
priorité puisqu'il a été créé une
quinzaine d'années avant homo
rodesiensis donc d'après cette nouvelle
recherche ils sont de la même espèce
mais comme je le disais tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord les scientifiques du
journal du journal evolutionary
anthropology ont décidé que homoodesien
6 qui date d' entre 400000 et 120000
125000 ans devrait être maintenant
appelé BO N6 d'après le crâne de Bodo en
Éthiopie qui vient d'art en Éthiopie et
cela enlèverait la référence à rod mais
comme j'ai dit ça provoque un énorme
problème taxonomique donc c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée ne serait-ce
que du point de vue taxonomique c'est
déjà pas une bonne idée rod était un
impérialiste un homme un businessman un
homme politique qui a joué un rôle
dominant en Afrique du Sud au 19e siècle
en étant le principal instigateur de
l'annexation de grande de grands
territoires donc notamment le comme je
le disais l'orange Free State le kazulu
Natal le Transval la zomie et enfin ce
qui est aujourd'hui la Zambie et le
Zimbabwe la campagne qui a depuis qui
dure depuis très longtemps à à
l'université d'Oxford et qui s'appelle
rads mustfall donc rods doit tomber
avait à la base demander le de à ce
qu'on enlève sa statue au collège oriel
et ça on en a eu les contrecoups j'en
profite pour le dire on en a eu les
contrecoups en Afrique du Sud où ils ont
aussi voulu abattre les statutes de de
Cécile rods qui se trouve au cap et ils
en ont il y en a deux et je crois qu'ils
en ont abattu une si je me rappelle bien
et ils ont abattu beaucoup d'autres
statu au passage mais ça a été une très
très grosse manifestation entre 2017 et
2020 en gros bah les les les quatre les
TR qu années avant le covid en réalité
on avait des manifestations étudiantes
énormément de manifestations étudiantes
et il y a beaucoup beaucoup de statut
euh d'e figies de personnages
historiques d'origine européenne qui
sont tombés dont certaines de Cécile
rods euh justement parce que les les
étudiants appelaient à une
décolonisation et qu'ils en avaient
marre de voir la tronche de gens qui ont
tué leurs ancêtres quoi c'est et et
encore une fois ça peut se comprendre
même si encore et encore une fois on
peut débattre sur faut-il détruire
l'histoire ou au contraire euh mettre un
petit panneau en expliquant ok on a
laissé la statue de rods mais c'était
pas un monsieur gentil quoi
mais on l'a gardé par pur intérêt
historique débat éternel mais le point
Godwin étant ce qu'il est on peut faire
appel au point Godwin et dire
garderiez-vous vous citoyens français
garderiez-vous une statue d'Adolf Hitler
sur la place du village juste parce que
c'est l'histoire et il faut pas oublier
l'histoire bon je sais que comparer
Cecile RS à Adolf Hitler c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être un peu extrême c'est
tout est une question de contexte le le
grand traumatisme ici en Afrique du Sud
ce n'est pas la Seconde Guerre mondiale
ils ne l'ont pas connu elle n'a pas elle
elle a eu un effet quasi négligeable en
particulier sur les populations euh non
africanur et non non européennes euh
enfin qui ne sont pas dans cettere
européen les populations d'origine non
européenne en Afrique du Sud la la
guerre la Seconde Guerre mondiale ça
leurait passé mais complètement
au-dessus leur grand traumatisme à eux
ça a été la colonisation
ça a été
l'apide c'est ça leur grand traumatisme
donc effectivement pour eux le ressenti
qu'ils ont en voyant qu' une statue
glorifiant cil rads bah oui deso mais
pas deso point Godwin oblige mais pour
eux c'est Adolf Hitler c'est c'est du
même niveau de traumatisme predra
gradovic du département d'archéologie de
l'Université de Belgrade a dit au Daily
télégraphe la connexion avec Cécile rod
ne représente pas l'argument principal
avec le fait de rejeter le le nom de
taxon mais c'est un problème qui ne doit
pas être ignoré malgré tout nous pensons
que le le but de la décolonisation de la
paléontologie est important et qu'il est
socialement responsable euh de de le
faire en effet sicil rad est un
personnage problématique justement le
mot problématique est en dropé dans
l'article c'est maintenant justement où
on peut lancer des pistes de discussion
maintenant dans l'autre direction parce
que ce mot problématique
euh il est très mal défini alors certes
Adolf Hitler est un nom problématique je
l'accorde et la pauvre espèce la pauvre
espèce de de scarabé qui a été nommé
anoltalmus hitlery d'après Adolf Hitler
je pense qu'on devrait la renommer
effectivement parce que je pense que le
monde entier sauf quelques illuminés est
d'accord pour dire que Adolf Hitler est
un personnage qui est extrêmement
problématique et en plus il y a la bonne
raison que de toute façon à cause de son
nom anophtalmus hitlery bah il y a un
marché noir en fait de ces B là il y a
un marché noir qui fait que l'espèce en
plus est en danger parce que anoftalmus
hitlery est un petit un petit insecte
qui vit dans des grottes qui vide que
dans une poignée de grotte voire même
que dans une seule grotte je me rappelle
plus exactement mais bref les illuminés
en question collectionne les petits
anophtalmus hitlery au point que
maintenant il y a un marché noir et il y
a du il y a du braconnage et l'espèce a
quasiment est en danger d'extinction à
cause de ce marché noir donc là oui il
faudrait renommer cette espèce je pense
pas que ça résoudra le problème c'est
trop tard maintenant mais au moins on
aura
essayé bon mais le niveau de
problématique maintenant c'est quoi
c'est c'est où est-ce qu'on définit
maintenant ce ce niveau de problématique
si on commence à prendre cette décision
qu'il y a des personnages politiques
comme Adolf Hitler ou Cécile rods qui
sont suffisamment problématiques pour
qu'on renomme les espèces qui ont été
nommées en leur honneur bah jusqu'à quel
point on va pousser ce niveau de
problématique par exemple Charles Darwin
voilà il y a énormément d'espèces qui
ont qui ont été nommées d'après Charles
Darwin en l'honneur de Charles Darwin je
veux dire c'est le père fondateur de la
biologie moderne la biologie évolutive
moderne donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'espèces qui ont été nommées en
l'honneur de Charles Darwin bon mais
Charles Darwin c'est un personnage de
son époque il était dans son jus et son
jus c'était l'Angleterre coloniale
victorienne donc Charles Darwin il avait
des opinions il avait et il avait des
comportements il a fait un usage de mots
qui aujourd'hui serait considéré
problématique si quelqu'un d'aujourd'hui
les employait où est-ce qu'on tracee la
limite entre ce qui est problématique et
ce qu' ne l''est pas c'està-dire est-ce
que Charles Darwin est suffisamment
intouchable pour ne jamais être
considéré comme étant problématique
alors même qu'il a tenu des propos qui
aujourd'hui bah ne passeraient plus et
tout ça ça pose de fait la question de
où on place cette barre du problématique
parce que je suis tout à fait d'accord
comme vous avez pu l'entendre je suis
tout à fait d'accord pour dire qu'il y a
des noms qui sont suffisamment
problématiques pour qu'on s'en
débarrasse mais du coup où place-ton
cette barre du problématique et à partir
du moment où on a créé une jurisprudence
en renommant une espèce parce que son la
personne sur laquelle cette espèce était
basée était problématique bah à partir
du moment on a créé cette jurisprudence
où est-ce qu'on s'arrête et ça ça c'est
ça c'est une grosse question parce que
la plupart des espèces qui ont été
nommées avant le enfin avant le la 2è
moitié du 20e siècle he donc avant le
grand traumatisme de la de la grande de
la 2uxème Guerre mondiale la plupart des
espèces qui ont été nommés avant ça vont
porter des noms problématiques parce que
c'est des gens qui appartenaient à une
autre époque avec une autre culture avec
une autre un autre standard de de la
biéance un autre standard de de ce qui
était bon pour la société donc oui vous
allez finir par tomber sur des
esclavagistes littéralement autre autre
point de réflexion aussi
homorodesiensis et que je n'ai pas enfin
que j'ai vaguement mentionné mais
maintenant je vais je vais en parler
réellement
homorodesiensis n'est pas un nom donné
en l'honneur de rods directement rods a
un pays nommé en son nom la Rhodésie et
homo rodésiensis est nommé en l'honneur
de ce pays enfin en fonction de ce pays
rodisien 6 qui vient de
rodésie parce que s'il était nommé
directement d'après Cécile Rodes il
s'appellerait r rodesil rodesi enfin il
y aurait un i à la fin quoi ce serait
rod ici comme comme là mais avec un i à
la fin donc Rodes en anglais rodesi en
français du coup donc c'est c'est pas
rods qui est mis à l'honneur dans le nom
homoodésiensis c'est la rodésie en
réalité donc rodésie où le crâne avait
le crâne de caboué ici avait été
découvert à
l'époque donc c'est une association
indirecte avec Cécil rad et donc une
fois de plus ça ça ça met immédiatement
la barre à un certain niveau sur ce
qu'on va être considéré comme étant
tolérable et considéré comme étant
intolérable et donc si déjà on commence
à considérer rodesien 6 comme étant
intolérable alors que ce n'est pas
directement nommé en référence à à à
Cécile R
bah ça place déjà la le le niveau
d'exigence euh je sais pas si on dirait
très bas ou très haut mais vous voyez ce
que je veux dire quoi ça place déjà la
barre à un certain niveau qui qui est
compliqué à gérer parce que va du coup
il va y avoir beaucoup de monde qui vont
devoir passer à l'échafud enfin beaucoup
de NS d'espèces qui vont devoir passer à
l'échafaud avec un niveau d'exigence
aussi
indirect voyez ou où ça mène et c'est
pour ça que je disais je ne peux que
vous amener des pistes de réflexion
parce que c'est un c'est insoluble c'est
absolument insoluble et comme je le
disais c'est parce qu'on veut partir je
pense moi dans mon dans mon fort
intérieur je pense que c'est parce que
on veut partir sur une décolonisation
destructrice une une déconstruction de
la colonisation alors qu'en réalité moi
je pense il faudrait bâtir par-dessus
c'estàdire votre statue vous ne devriez
pas la vous ne devriez pas faire tomber
la statue vous devriez faire une
meilleure statue par-dessus voilà et
comme ça on verrait plus la gueule de
rods et on verrait la gueule de
quelqu'un qu'on aime bien à la place
mais la statue de R ne serait pas perdu
ou en l'occurrence vous la mettez dans
un musée voilà vous mettez la statue de
rads dans un musée si elle a vraiment un
intérêt historique cette statue vous la
foutez dans un musée vous mettez une
autre statue à sa place comme ça la
statue n'est pas détruite la statue est
remplacée mais l'histoire est conservée
et vous mettez un petit encar en disant
il y avait autrefois une statue de rose
ici mais on l'a virait parce que Rose on
l'aime plus voilà à l'époque c'était
normal de de le considérer comme un
héros aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas il
faut moderniser notre science il faut
moderniser la façon dont on
conçoit notre science il faut moderniser
le cadre politique dans lequel on
pratique notre science aussi beaucoup de
nos collègues ne sont pas à l'aise à
l'idée de renommer de d'utiliser pardon
le nem rodesensis pour une espèce
domininé le professeur Chris Stringer du
Muséum d'histoire naturelle dont vous
dira pas où qui a été inclus dans cette
étude donc l'étude de Bodo N6 et
d'accord à avec le fait que le système
de nomenclature doit être réorganisé il
a dit que le code international de
nomenclature donc le fameux code
international de nomenclature dont je
parle depuis tout à l'heure les règles
de priorité et cetera est très clair sur
le fait donc ce code international de
nomenclature est très clair sur le fait
que vous ne pouvez pas juste renommer
une espèce parce que le nom ne vous
plaît pas parce que autrement c'est la
porte ouverte à la prolifération
taxonomique c'est la porte ouverte à des
gens qui vont débarquer en disant faut
tout décoloniser et du coup comme je le
disais il y a il y a des milliers de
noms d'espèces qui ont été donnés et qui
peuvent être considérés comme étant
comme ayant été nommé en l'honneur de
gens qui étaient problématiques comme
Charles Darwin par exemple et donc il y
a des gens qui vont se faire des
carrières entières à juste publier des
articles en disant faut renommer ça faut
renommer ça faut renommer ça et ils vont
créer de des nouveaux noms d'espèces
mais juste bah alors il y a ceux qui le
feront de bonne foi mais il y a tous les
autres qui le feront juste pour se faire
une carrière juste pour profiter de la
vibe et surfer sur ce ce nouveau
mouvement de la décolonisation en disant
e regardez moi je suis super décolonisé
j'ai fait 3 millions de publications o
dans chacune d'entre elles j'ai renommé
une espèce et boum le mec il a un CV
long comme le
bras mais qui qui au final ne consiste
qu'à renommer des espèces sous le
prétexte qu'il faut les décoloniser
encore une fois c'est la cette règle de
priorité c'est pas une règle qui existe
pour maintenir des noms qui sont problém
tique c'est une règle qui existe pour
éviter la prolifération taxonomique pour
éviter que des gens se fassent des
carrières entières à juste nommer des
espèces comme ça juste parce que le nom
ancien ne leur plaît pas puis encore une
fois où est-ce qu'on tracee la limite
parce que certes là on ne parle que des
espèces qui ont un nom problématique
mais quand est-ce qu'on va se mettre à
parler des espèces qui ont été nommées
par des gens problématiques vous pensiez
pas qu'on irait aussi loin en parlant de
décoloniser la la paléontologie mais en
réalité ça va loin décoloniser la
paléontologie nous vivons dans un monde
qui est post-colonial certes mais qui en
réalité par beaucoup de nos attitudes
dont on ne se rend même pas compte est
en réalité néocolonial c'est les pays
dans lesquels on vit ont encore des
influences monumental dans leurs
anciennes colonies quand ces colonies
sont effectivement décolonisé ce qui est
pas forcément le cas de beaucoup de
DomTom hein donc n nous vivons dans des
pays qui ont encore des inf influence
coloniale ou qui sont encore sous
influence coloniale et ça ça se ressent
dans la science de tous les jours
l'écrasante majorité des publications
scientifiques viennent du nord viennent
de l'hémisphère Nord viennent des pays
de de l'ouest de l'Occident et ce qu'on
constate c'est que ces chercheurs
beaucoup d'entre eux ne se gênent pas
pour venir faire de la recherche dans
les anciens pays colonisés ils font leur
bouibi et puis ils s'en vont sans rien
laisser derrière eux donc quand c'est
quand il s'agit de fossil par exemple ça
c'est arrivé par le passé et ça arrive
encore aujourd'hui que les fossiles ils
se font embarquer et ils reviennent
jamais dans leur pays d'origine
ubirajara étant un des exemples de de de
de ces fossiles qui ont été embarqués
mais qui n'ont jamais été
restitués donc ça ça arrive c'est ce
qu'on appelle de la de l'hélicopter
science de la science hélicoptère voyez
on drop on fait ce qu'on a à faire on
monte dans l'hélicoptère on se
casse tout ça bah sans participer à
l'éducation du pays sans par participer
à l'élaboration d'un musée local sans
donc ça on évite de plus en plus de le
faire et il y a de plus en plus de
programmes de financement qui vont
participer à développer des musées
locaux développer l'éducation
locale afin que justement bah ces
fossiles puissent ensuite être restitué
à des musées qui auront du personnel
compétent du personnel local
compétent mais bah ça coûte de l'argent
c'est pas facile à faire donc il y en a
beaucoup qui qui cèdent à la facilité a
beaucoup qui cèdent à la facilité et
tous les ans il y a des scandales et si
vous vous sentez pas concerné par ça bah
réfléch
réfléchissez-y à deux fois parce que en
réalité vous vous venez de le vivre à
l'instance les conséquences de cette
colonisation qui n'est en réalité pas
terminé vous les vivez vous-même à
l'instant aujourd'hui vous en tant que
francophone certainement basé en France
vous avez vu défiler des articles là
devant votre écran qui sont en anglais
et ces article la raison pour laquelle
ils sont en anglais bah c'est pourquoi
c'est à cause des des Britanniques les
Britanniques l'Empire sur lequel le
soleil ne se couchait jamais bah c'est
devenu plus facile de communiquer en
anglais vu qu'ils étaient absolument
partout et vu qu'ils ont dominé le monde
pendant tout le tout le 19e siècle et
aujourd'hui c'est les États-Unis qui ont
pris le relais de la domination du monde
entre guillemets économiquement au moins
et politiquement et culturellement donc
aujourd'hui c'est les États-Unis qui ont
pris le relais mais les États-Unis c'est
pareil pourquoi est-ce qu'ils parlent
anglais aux États-Unis bah c'était une
colonie britannique donc voyez c'est la
la raison pour laquelle vous avez vu des
articles défilés la raison pour laquelle
la science est en anglais c'est à cause
de ça c'est la colonisation c'est un
reste de la colonisation c'est pour ça
qu'il faut se sentir concerné par ça
parce que ça nous touche aussi
finalement bon c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo vous pouvez débattre dans les
commentaires mais je vous assure que je
vais avoir une poigne de faire sur la
modération vous pouvez en avoir la
certitude je vous dis à très bientôt sur
notre chaîne
salut